that's zendaya out and about in new york
city with tom holland and her boyfriend
is lucky to have an actress and a
fashion icon as his shopping partner i
am sweating on wednesday the couple made
a rare public outing in the big apple
and judging from these ensembles it
seems they were looking to keep a low
profile
zendaya chic as ever wore a long tan
coat gray pants black boots topped off
with a black bucket hat i just feel very
lucky meanwhile tom donned dark jeans a
red coat and a black beanie much like
their other public appearances there
wasn't much pda seen here but we did
spot tom holding zendaya's arm outside
their suv and the couple's latest
sighting follows their trip abroad last
month where zendaya and tom were seen
visiting his family in london this also
comes after the two coach starred in
spider-man no way home
[Music]
fun fact as of this week it is now the
third highest grossing movie of all time
i honestly feel a little bit numb and
remember when zendaya stopped tom in his
tracks at the premiere party how are you
feeling about that and tackling that
they're losing things i think zendaya
just sounds like xander just showed up
and this couple's love story has been a
journey i think you know right now it's
just the beginning of this really
adorable uh romance that we're watching
kind of bloom on camera dating rumors
first begin in the summer of 2017 amid
the actors worldwide press tour for
spider-man homecoming have you found
that it's hard to date in hollywood so
at such a young age of course it is i
mean it's hard today at any age i mean
it doesn't matter you know where you are
either i mean it's just hard to say in
general but zendaya shut down the
speculation at the time when she simply
called tom quote one of her best friends
and a quote great dude in that august
zendaya told et she wasn't phased by
their romance rumors it happens all the
time and of course you know we we
expected it i mean it's it's um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good cut to
2021 the couple was seen packing on the
pda around los angeles i'm excited we're
gonna have a good press tour i think in
november holland officially confirmed
the relationship to gq and will the
couple work together outside the marvel
universe well i don't know how excited
people would be to just jump on board
while chatting with et about season two
of euphoria zendaya joked how tom could
land a cameo in the hit hbo series your
boy tom holland said he would love a
cameo i mean what does he have to do to
show up for season three listen we
talked about it you know cause uh
um he supported me through the whole the
whole season and you know we joke about
like just spitting him into the
background
it was an easter egg see if someone can
can spot him